>> So, we've got a whole bunch of trees we have
to look at, Michael. And were going to have to come up with
some clever way to look through them. And this get's us
back, something that we've talked about before, which is the notion of
bias. And in particular, the notion of inductive bias. Now, just
as a quick refresher, I'm want to remind you that there is
two kind of biases we worrying about when we think about algorithms
that are searching through space. One is what's called a restriction bias.
The other is called preference bias.
So a restriction bias is nothing more than
the hypothesis set that you actually care about. So
in this case, with the decision trees, the
hypothesis set is all possible decision trees. Okay? That
means we're not considering, y equals 2x plus
3. We're not considering quadratic equations. We're not considering
non-boolean functions of a certain type. We're only considering
decision trees, and all that they can represent. And
nothing else. Okay? So that's already a restriction bias
and it's important. Because, instead of looking at the infinite
number uncountably infinite number of functions that are out there,
that we might consider. We're only going to consider those
that can be represented by a decision tree over
in, you know, all the cases we've given so far
discreet variable. But a preference bias is something that's just
as important. And it tells us what source of hypotheses
from this hypothesis set we prefer,
and that is really at the heart of inductive bias. So Michael,
given that, what would you say is the inductive
bias of the ID3 algorithm? That is, given a whole
bunch of decision trees, which decision trees would ID3 prefer,
over others?
>> So, it definitely tries, since it's, since it's making
it's decisions top down. It's going to be more likely to produce a tree that has
basically good splits near the top than a tree that has bad splits
at the top. Even if the two trees can represent the same function.
>> Good point.
So good splits near the top.
Alright. And you said something very important
there Michael. Given two decision trees that
are both correct. They both represent the,
the function that we might care about.
It would prefer the one that had the better split near the top. Okay,
so any other preferences? Any other inductive bias on the, on the ID3 algorithm.
>> It prefers ones that model the data
better to ones that model the data worse.
>> Right. So this is one that people often forget: it prefers
correct ones to incorrect ones. So, given a tree that has very
good splits at the top but produces the wrong answer. It will
not take that one over one that doesn't have as good splits at
the top, but does give you the correct answer. So that's really,
those are really the two main things that are the inductive bias
for ID3. Although, when you put those two together, in particular when
you look at the first one, there's sort of a third one that
comes out as well, which is ID3 algorithm tends to
prefer shorter trees to longer trees. Now, that preference for shorter
trees actually comes naturally from the fact that you're doing
good splits at the top. Because you're going to take trees
that actually separate the data well by labels, you're going to
tend to come to the answer faster than you would if
you didn't do that. So, if you go back to
the example where we went before, where one of the attributes
doesn't split the data at all, that is not something that ID3 would
go for, and it would in fact create a longer and unnecessarily longer tree.
So it tends to prefer shorter trees over longer trees. So long as
they're correct and they give you good splits near the top of the tree.